doink doink doink yeah yeah double doink
doink doink feeling it feeling it FIFA
feeling it doing doing how was your
weekend it was good it's good I don't
feel great yeah you can you'll say well
yeah it's what happens when you're great
I got it from you carry your monkey
listen that's the point is I've passed
it along to you blood brothers gosh you
guys don't realize though I can't win
these ones like an L cuz you got no
spleen yeah yeah we know way to bring it
all about your face all about your
spleen that's right you went on
television you did your thing you said
the Bears we're gonna win oopsie oopsie
seven and three now which is I want to
say for you to do ten picks on NBC and
you're seven and three and everyone else
is nine and eight damn good out in that
game and I still I still pissed off to
the Steelers lost to the Chargers that
night you could have been nine and one
could have been against the Eagles in
the charger apparently before we get
going and recap all four games by the
way this is how we're doing it this week
today is gonna be kind of recapping
everything some of the storylines and
and putting some of the teams to rest
Wednesday we're gonna do all film yes or
so we're not gonna do any film today
we're gonna save it for Wednesday so you
can really dive in and then Thursday is
our gambling betting forecasting yeah
and for that show too I will definitely
go back into you know cow no not that
game what the hell am I thinking of
what's our rematch from this big eagles
saying sorry yeah and I will go back and
have some tidbits from that game I don't
really know what you're gonna glean from
that game yeah my 41 I would not they're
not gonna lose my 41 they're certainly
not you could hey the Eagles are back
they're back this is the game I needed
to see to believe it okay just so you
know but they have gotten back to what
made them a really good football team
last year can you do me a favor ask me
that the Oracle
I like you touch my ball yours yeah only
one of us went for it oh this past week
only one of us made a perfect $1,600
look at you losing money all to 1590
that I made you lost $10 ago I a few
things just from the gambling
perspective do you realize that no in
the super in the last two playoffs
underdogs are 15 and one against the
spread in the playoffs the last two
playoffs Wow
because yesterday all four are the last
this past weekend all four underdogs
covered because for a lot of people
Dallas was true in the house covered
right we got it at one and a half right
right so we still cover it we still
cover so what was the one that didn't
cover do you know did you look it up
don't give me stats like this and tell
me they're 15 and one it was sometime
last year I'm gonna guess it's the
Patriot I mean damn I'm gonna guess it's
the Patriot damn damn okay who did the
Patriots play the divisional Brown last
year who would they play before they
play the Jacksonville Jaguars Titans
they beat the rest that was I kicked you
out of the house when he threw the
amazing third down throw where Brady ran
to the right yeah you kicked us out of
like I don't see nothing like this game
wasn't that it was like there was like
you guys wanted to make the Train it was
like 180 minutes left in the game yeah
and he made that amazing scramble the
right and threw it across the field I
was like alright it's over let's go over
it's over
before we get going and we're talking
about Super Bowl and all that stuff we
want to officially give you the schedule
if you're joining us in Atlanta and I'm
getting a ton of DMS from people saying
that they're gonna be in Atlanta we have
a system that we need to do because
we're worried it's getting packed but I
want to do it because we want you guys
there we are going to be at Dan Tana's
in the CNN center that is Dan Tana's in
the CNN sometimes with Santana but it's
Dan yeah it's a huge bar they're giving
us their spot for the week right near
the stadium it's right in your radio row
there's a bunch of hotels and bars it's
going to be like right outside the NFL
experience so it's easy to get to in
downtown Atlanta but that's gonna be our
spot Tuesday at five o'clock we're doing
a podcast Wednesday at five o'clock
we're doing a podcast this is the week
leading up to the Super Bowl
Thursday at six o'clock we're taping our
show Friday at 4:30 we're doing our
podcast here's how this is gonna work
email are we get to our show live that
week thirty were taping become of the
next but email Sims and Lefko at
gmail.com give us sort of like your name
and some information and how many people
because there's gonna be like seeding
and all that stuff for you guys to
reserve seating because there's also
gonna be random people coming in because
we're gonna have big-name guests like
they're going out and getting us like
big-name football players like yeah I
don't want to problem is anything so
then you're the big thing is send your
name let's do full name and how many
people - Sims and left go at gmail.com
again that's Tuesday and Wednesday we're
recording at five Thursday at 6
Friday at 4:30 but dude I want to say
this also for everyone that said oh I'm
gonna come in for the draft I don't
think it's happening guys like I'm just
gonna put it out there
Atlanta though is the full weight of the
bleacher report we're gonna have a suit
studio we're gonna have a set we're
gonna have a bunch activities there
we're gonna do trivia with you guys
we're gonna be hanging out when we're
not recording we're gonna just just be
kicking it with athletes and you guys so
if you can make it to Atlanta the week
leading up to the Super Bowl Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday and Friday at Dan
Tana's we'd love to see you there cool
it's the first time we're doing it yeah
I'm excited for it I'm excited to be
cool dad the audience there and just
interact I'm excited for the first time
they all kind of get in and get
comfortable yeah and then you say
something very off-color and everyone's
like like what up [ __ ] and then
welcome Dan Dan Tana's yes yes exactly
look at all these [ __ ] yeah
I feel like I've heard of Dan Tana's
before there more than one is this just
a singular entity in the antenna it's
the only Dan Tana's in the world
wow that's a lot yeah I thought of July
I feel like I know Dan Tana's I just
don't know where from all right we are
gonna start this game okie start we'll
be just with the Bears and the Eagles
well how about this I'll let you start
wherever you want let's start with the
Bears and the Eagles yes respect for the
Super Bowl champions you got it pal I
like a little respect I give respect
even though I am rooting so hard against
you mofos I don't care
where's my say tat I want a Saint hat I
want one of those pointy Saint hats I am
now full new jack city I am wearing a
ski mask just shut the [ __ ] up
ha ha ha yeah did you get that I tried
to tell you I said two curses so far
josh is already on me listeners I tried
to tell you you doubted the Eagles you
thought that the Bears could match up
with them and push them around and that
Nick Foles was nothing but a hologram
well let me tell you something what you
witnessed was perfection the Bears got
the exact game that they wanted me to
try Biscay threw for 300 yards Alan
Robinson broke the all-time record for
Chicago Bears receptions or receiving
yards in a playoff game Nick Foles had
two turnovers the Eagles had costly
penalties that extended bears drives one
penalty ensure that they got a punt for
them at the one making them try and
exist in a shadow of their own goalpost
but it was the goalpost that set them
free Hector with the block you can talk
all you want about a missed field goal
the best defense in the NFL allowed a
12-play
80 yard drive with a fourth down
touchdown one year before the Atlanta
Falcons tried to drive on the Eagles and
it came down to a fourth down play on
the 2 yard line with 58 seconds left no
good the Eagles 58 seconds left 4th down
2 yard line
Oh guess what
good not just good gold good no golden
go then good golden golden God the
Eagles are clicking and I lost my
headset it doesn't matter I don't need
to hear myself because the only thing I
hear is the swansong coming off of Nick
Foles Golden Arm the Eagles are back and
now guess who are taking on yeah the
most overrated quarterback in the
history of the NFL a guy that shouldn't
even be mentioned in the same breath of
the MVP conversation is Patrick mahomes
this week is gonna be glorious let's go
Saints let's go say so I just hope you
know it's all the same Superbowl and I'm
riding with the Saints this week cuz I
can't take it
Philadelphia was a great story in 2017
I can't take it anymore as a resident
Giants fan I've had enough of the story
and I am never rooted harder against
your football team perfect and I will
this way that's what fuels us right I
want to apologize to all the Sims Lefko
fans that didn't realize I was like this
it happened last year during the
playoffs it's happening right now it's a
level of fury that I'm not used to leave
that on let's see how sweaty your
forehead gets this I'm leaving this on
the entire show okay good
be those kurosu just lick the edges the
eye it is funny I mean just to start
there and I really was sitting there I
really thought all week that the Bears
were like your Eagles team last year
right you were saying and then then they
got down there on the fourth and fourth
and goal and I'm like holy cow this is
like Atlanta Eagles and watch I thought
about you a number of times during the
game yesterday but let me say this much
I always root the better team
I root for the better team and I
understand I want to see the better
games the next week
and let me just tell you this oh my gosh
the better team one you play you right
now are better than they are you were
better yesterday and you've been playing
better the last few weeks what is he to
see yesterday to kind of confirm it
because I didn't fill you mean I thought
you matched up really well with the
Redskins and an inadequate quarterback
and a banged up offensive line the
Houston Texans we see their whole lives
not very
right so I just thought oh these Rams
office right bad point I just had that
you said you didn't think that the front
for the Eagles could create that much
pressure right one Mitch yet they did
and I think the Bears old-line did
pretty good also too
but yes I mean just overall the Eagles
were the better football team your
Eagles have gotten back into what has
made them a special football team we've
talked about that you're healthy on both
sides of line it's a rebirth of Timmy
turn again to go along with Fletcher Cox
and Michael Bennett right there's to get
Jordan Hicks and Nigel Branham at
linebacker they didn't have that last
year exactly right can you like they
took advantage a lot the Bears did and
sure Biscay did of like crow Vaughn
LeBlanc and Avante Maddox a few times
sure but overall they're just all
playing better what are you gonna Rasul
Douglas it doesn't make any sense well I
think the big thing is is you know
they've really simplified things in the
backend something that we were crying
for early in the year likes less is less
crazy things in the cover let's just be
good at what we do and be sound and
simple and that's really what the Eagles
have been they've got just as fresh for
we're gonna keep seven in the backend
everybody's gonna do their job and as
everybody does their singular job we
will be great as a unit that's really
what they bought into I watch guys like
Malcolm Jenkins making it mean that's
the one thing I respect about the game
tell me well he's got all these young
and experienced guys around him and if
you watch Malcolm Jenkins during the
game mean he's he must say nine
paragraphs before each play it looks
like dory what to do he's always going
you know this and he's giving signals
and he's telling this guy but it's an
amazing job not only by the team itself
but Jim Schwartz you got to give him
credit Doug Peterson once again and some
of the magic that he is able to pull off
especially and got to have it plays or
situations but yes you outplayed the
Chicago Bears yesterday and you were the
better football team and really probably
would have controlled the game if Foles
doesn't throw the two bonehead
interceptions to where you dictated the
flow of the game from there on out and
lastly dropped three interceptions and
one of them yes could've been a pick
exactly right had some chances early on
certainly and they dropped a few picks
too so I don't always like
that waiters but yeah Foles taking an
advantage of some matchups outside that
was huge and what was the other thing I
was going to say Oh to your point on
your your you know your speech you gave
there at the beginning
I mean you're exactly right the Bears
got the game exactly where they wanted
like this was not a favorite they would
assign the contract that they said
Eagles give you thirty eight rushing
yards right yeah five point lead with
four minutes left and we take it right
now yeah they would be like oh yeah
we'll take that we're gonna win the game
then and yeah ain't your bus keys nuts
over 300 yards yes they would be like
double sign let me do that sure the
statistics were a Bears win yeah you
really were right uh how about this
little nugget this is from Kapadia down
there in the athletic in Philadelphia
yeah Eagles have faced Aaron Donald JJ
Watt and Khalil Mak during this
four-game winning streak yeah those
three players have combined for a total
of zero sacks and three quarterback hits
against them it's pretty impressive JJ
Watt he fell off towards the end of this
season
I'll just tell that everybody JJ Watt
still phenomenal I get that but JJ Watt
had troubles it gets Braden Smith the
other day and the Colts game - he
certainly kind of lost steam down the
stretch but your old line being healthy
and the fact that yes when your old
lines healthy we've talked about it last
year and you know you're one of the
biggest teams in football and you don't
need to help out certain guys in your
line but you have to see but I'm very
excited yeah so when you have that
healthy what we said it last year I was
just saying but I know we didn't get
into these specific points this year but
you don't need to help anybody and guy
like Jason Peters I know you heard me
say this earlier today the really big
tackles give Khalil Mack the issue
Khalil Mack really makes his money
usually overpowering the 315 pound tell
because Cleo Mack even though he's 255
260 packs an incredible punch and you
have seen him in person and know how
powerful he is but when he doesn't have
the power he's not the type of guy that
can win with speed consistently and
Jason Peters
Kaleo Mack ain't gonna beat him with
power so that's where I think that
matchup really worked out but then you
have Brandon Brooks to go I can car I
can block Akeem Hicks by my
yes you know those are the things and
then Lane Jim still had a quarter that
is he did he still had a great game but
they didn't you guys aren't ruined or
compromised when you leave your old line
five-on-four where a lot of other teams
are compromised in that situation and it
ruins their game plans Eagle still felt
the need to run sideline to sideline the
fear much for no reason yeah nick foles
I didn't think played great Golden Tate
really made a big statement game for him
and Sharon Chai's Alshon Jeffery is my
favorite receiver and the history of the
Eagles he is because the competition is
what Harold Carmichael he needs a lot
like Howard Carmichael a little bit and
Carmichael wore what 17 no Howard
Carmichael wore number 17 I mean you
have Google but I'm just saying that al
Shawn Jeffrey's performance in the Super
Bowl last year what he does on a regular
basis and how he's come alive he's
incredible yes but I really thought one
of the big play 17 that's also they were
the same thing I'm a Redskins fan I mean
I'm an Eagles fan the the the last drive
second and ten yeah the ball is thrown
at the feet of Dallas Goddard scoops it
up gets hit by three guys spins out and
somehow gets the first down he also had
the touchdown earlier Dallas got hurt
ended up being a real weapon for this
offense yeah and I love it especially
this like the thing about the Eagles
they play like a young person doesn't
Madden which is when you're thrown
across the middle you just throw it high
throw it high to Al Shean throw it high
to urge throw it high to Goddard because
when you're playing a team like Chicago
you can out-jump those yes Kyle fuller
Amukamara there's no holes oh my god you
know who said that
all day yesterday is Tony Dungy and I
got to give him credit again he's all
over the Eagles right now like he's been
spot-on he has he doesn't beat the Rams
oh yeah he's been spot-on about that
what's he been saying well he said that
point right there he goes I don't think
maybe the Eagles to be able to do a lot
of the things they want to do in the
short passing game they'd fold so
successful but he goes the problem I
worry about is I don't think these
corners can match up with some of the
size of the Earth's or the Alshon
Jeffery Xand and that was a valid point
and that certainly bared to be true
where were you when the kick went up I
was in my house sitting there with uh
you know Charlotte Danielle and Phillip
Phillip was
for the Eagles really why he loves Nick
Foles yes yeah he's all he's always been
on Nick Foles since last year so you
think it was going in um when he got the
practice shot I said oh Doug Peterson
messed up he called the timeout too late
and gave this guy practice shot he's
gonna make it now that's what I thought
I was for the issues here I didn't know
it wasn't a slam dunk but I thought
since he got that practice swing guys to
do that doesn't bode well for the Eagles
yeah I crazy game so you know when
you're some game so you've probably
never experienced this as you can tell
I'm superstitious yeah when I watch a
game clothing comes off clothing comes
back on yesterday I had a hoodie I had
two Eagle socks on around the fourth
quarter all that stuff came off I'm
sitting there at a t-shirt my underwear
I found one spot in the corner that led
to a fourth to a first down on the couch
and then towards the end of the drive I
began holding one part of my couch and
the other part of my couch and that got
the Golden Tate touchdown that did it
was all about you you know was the enemy
as the book you need to read okay then
for the field goal I went back to that
and when he made the first one I went
damn it you know like I always hear it
it settles the nerves to see it go
through and as soon as it came out I
thought it was good the second time I
didn't obviously notice the tip you know
everyone's talking about now that Hector
tip today ruled the NFL was officially
ruled in a block man yeah I get it but I
didn't you couldn't see it it's the yeah
the faintest of blocks way to go like
that's something like that but just
think target for a ball from 40 yards
away what however far it is 43 yards
away to go and hit a pole and then to go
horizontal means that it has to hit the
side of that poll so flush to just go
sideways and then for that ball to go
sideways it is now a 50/50 proposition
it's going to hit that ball that pole
that crossbar and go one of two
directions one way is the most
disappointing loss for a franchise
ruining a dream Super Bowl season for
the Bears and I want to say this to
Bears fans I am sorry I really am
like that's sitting there I of course
I've been there the amount of NFC
championship games I watched the Eagles
lost that's why I said if Mitchell
starts out slow I know what you're gonna
go through with fear so I'm sorry that
that happened from all Eagles fans I'm
sorry but if that went in that may have
been the most exciting playoff finish
ever yeah if that bounces off the
crossbar and goes in one NBC's killing
themselves that they didn't have the
right angle there that like it wasn't
like that
come on the slow-motion right but if it
goes in I mean that place may have
exploded yeah I mean that would have
been incredible to just fall in like
like some happy gilmore stuff yeah I
mean we've seen them fall in that way
before I mean and honestly when it went
off the upright and then hit the low I
thought it was in you couldn't tell the
truth tell them down I was like oh my
gosh it went in did i did i yelled out
do you hear that
and Neal's fans gave us the win by doing
that and then I realized it hit on the
goal line
oh no it's are you still salty that Nick
Foles is getting so much credit I don't
love it you know again he was the number
one story yesterday and I get that he
made a lot of great card listen I don't
want to take anything away from Nick
Foles I just want people to realize that
just to say it's him and Carson Wentz
was the issue I don't like that and I'm
gonna continue to fight against that
narrative because yes Carson Wentz
didn't have the benefit of the old line
being totally healthy or the D line
being exactly what it was it wasn't
Carson Wentz's fault you know Jimmy let
up 14 15 that would have ended the game
and I out rad against a Titan so you
know that's what's awesome about you
guys is you know all the games you were
supposed to win early on in the year you
found ways to lose them and now you're
finding ways to win though maybe you
have recaptured that magic and you
definitely are one of the eight best
teams in the NFL deserve to be where
you're at what's a better combination of
games Rams bears Saints Cowboys or Rams
Cowboys Saints Eagles Rams Cowboys irzu
Saints Eagles are Saints Cowboys yeah
probably see it's
I don't know I mean I don't I can't I
don't go wrong with any one of those I
don't I don't sit here and go I mean
right now for where we got the nick
foles Philadelphia Eagles Super Bowl
defending champion story is a sexier
story further to make football in the
weekend big review taken right now say a
sales yes I'm thinking the Saints time I
know I'm wearing a saint hat in here
next week this is perfect
I'm gonna wear that I'm gonna get at the
fleur-de-lis if the Eagles beat the
Saints right we need to do we need to
take Nick Foles to an exorcist after the
season after season make sure all the
spirits are aligned that was incredible
and the fact that on Friday I did an
interview with the Chicago radio station
and predicted that the Eagles would win
as the ball bounced off should I play
that audio sure it's amazing it's
amazing it came back to that I mean
that's that's what I think's hilarious
about this this is where life just
exceeds Hollywood you couldn't write
that ending know in Hollywood coach
Archy bangin one off and up the Nick
Foles story combined with it and that
going down and scoring a touchdown late
in the game I mean all of it was just
phenomenal this is a Chicago radio host
saying it's gonna be a high-scoring
Chicago and he was completely wrong and
then I curse because I forgot them on
radio believes because nobody knows
nobody knows I was in shock I was in
ecstasy for two-three hours afterwards
my girlfriend's watching the Golden
Globes and I was just sitting there
soaking it all in
I'm watching the video of the guy
blowing it on his TV screen and thinking
he blocked it I'm reading quotes from
Jason Peterson we've wanted revenge on
the Saints ever since they ran the score
up and I'm like oh my gosh we got a
chance
the best part is is this Eagles underdog
narrative is is still alive yeah of
course it is
it's incredible nobody expects how
empowering is that to a team Oh like
just fuel I mean it's just constantly
they're gonna be talked about how we're
disrespected they know what they hear
the biggest underdog of the weekend
exactly right and then to lose like that
like I told ya what'swhat's the locker
room doing what to lose like that not
only you motivated to get the second
shot right because you're mad at how the
first shot went but I think what even
furthers that is what I said to you
earlier today there's gonna be the fear
factor too which will make you even
better because there is gonna be whether
they want to admit it or not the Eagles
players there's gonna be the fear and
back of their mind going are we as good
as this team damn they beat us 48 to 7
you know what I mean which will help
them throughout the week to prepare
because they're gonna go damn we got to
play really good we know we can't mess
up
Foles can't throw to interception yeah
we can't mess up an end of the game
situation everybody's got to be all over
what is Sean Payton saying to his team
how do you get a team motivated for a
team that you beat by 41 points yeah
he's gonna he's gonna say a lot of the
things were saying that this is a
different team he's gonna show clips of
what they've done the last four weeks
and say you know hey remember he's a
master motivator the game against his
team watched the last game like that's
the kind of crap he might do you might
just roll him wipe it away don't even
worry about it this is not the same team
they don't do some of the same things
schematically look Sean Payton's a
master motivator before the Bengals game
when he was worried about a letdown
after the bye right smash the fire alarm
if you want to make sure that it goes
off and they destroyed Cincinnati but
yeah I just I feel like that same fear
and the Eagles I wonder are the Saints
right now like I know that we beat the
crap out of them and Saints haven't
played since week 16 rest of the
starters against the Panthers had off
last week yep no you you might can't
believe this you could catch him early
and jump out to attend nothing lead cuz
they're a little rusty and you guys have
been in playoff football games really
for the last three weeks so your battle
test and that's what happens a lot of
times in these type of matchups because
one team is going oh we're the cool
number one seed and then all sudden it's
like bam bam oh that was a right hook in
a jab to the face
wait we're in a playoff game here oh
damn we're down 10 nothing when I said
this about the Bears and I'll say about
the Saints when you're expected to win
and it starts crumbling yeah feared but
this is Drew Brees and Sean Payton so
Nick Foles has beaten the top ranked
defense in the playoffs two years in a
row last year the Vikings this year the
Chicago needs to be talked about through
briefs we're coming for you drew oh baby
were coming for ya okay the other thing
I was gonna say with the the Bears let's
just talk about them for a second if you
don't mind first of all Mitchell drew
Brisky was played really well you're
very happy about that well I just don't
want that to be the narrative I mean
that's just stupid I mean you know again
hey was he perfect in the first half no
but we're seeing that the Eagles defense
has made a lot of people not look that
perfect I mean deshaun Watson didn't
look that perfect against them a few
weeks ago either what'd you think about
Nicky's two-point conversion call
um what was Nicky's two-point conversion
call can't even think of the damn place
Taylor Gabriel Oh Taylor Gabe you'll run
right they tried to kind of fake dilly
dilly or Philly Philly and running up
the middle yeah I wasn't a huge fan of
that you know but it's thought out and
there's thought there I can always live
with that I don't just go that was
stupid they've done that play before
they've shown some of those with me what
the refs blowing it dead after the
incompletion yeah I don't like that rule
I mean what should have happened in your
mind in my mind I think logic would say
that they should get the ball where the
ball was released like to eat the Eagles
had a chance to recover that fumble not
really I know it's a very ver F game
over with no issue with that play I'm
not look either do I going oh you know
that's just uh one of those things that
happens and I don't really know if
there's a right fix to that situation
because you're right how are you gonna
live there and go well we're gonna give
them a completion when the Eagles maybe
could have picked it up but the whistle
was blown so they're listening to the
fact that this was blown and they're
seeing a referee saying
my biggest issue again is with the refs
blowing the whistle are calling plays
before they really know the Chargers not
to write just let the
I play out looked like a catch he took
three steps let it go call complete and
there's no reason to ever blow your
whistle there's really not but as we see
in these playoff games the refs can not
wait to blow their whistle one other
fundamental mistake I thought in this
game just schematically right the one
thing and I know I said this last week
rushing attempts would be important for
for the Eagles mean 21 rushing attempts
is that right my right of that 21 22 ok
that was just the right amount
just the right amount but there there
was on the other side and the Andy Reid
school tree and Heath runs the ball 12
times with his running backs the whole
game 12 times against the Philadelphia
Eagles Cris Collinsworth even said to
her the game I still think Jordan Howard
should be a because because when they
lined up under the center and ran it up
the middle they did it four times I
believe three or four times were gashes
and you mentioned the one play where
Malcolm Jenkins in his foot and Malcolm
Jenkins didn't hit his foot it was his
own player he tripped over
yeah if Jordan Howard Jordan American
house right there was a short yardage
situation where there was no second
level but yes the impatience there to
become that one-dimensional against a
defense that's not playing well I
thought ultimately really handicapped
the Bears and led to some of those stale
periods we saw in the third and fourth
quarter from their offense mmm
but either way great great bear season
great bear season bears watch out for
the Bears I mean the Bears are they got
the team to build and be around for a
while we'll see cuz Vic Fangio is out
doing interviews right now at the
Dolphins and some other team yeah they
can cancel those dolphins one day though
did he did but yeah they're at least
from the talent perspective they are
primed and ready to go for believe you
said the Eagles were the better team
they works me I'm always honest guy I'm
not here as much as I was going to the
Bears yesterday mask update it's getting
hot in here yeah take it off I don't
think so alright fine next one up yeah
which Keaney want to talk about okay you
lead the show no let's do chargers
Baltimore charge on reverse order seven
defensive backs on the field if I would
have told you that the Chargers were
load
up to stop the Ravens run offense I
would say well that means they're
probably getting a lot of big people out
there it's so unconventional wisdom that
it's beautiful Gus Bradley said we need
to get more defensive backs in the field
to deal with the side-to-side speed of
the Ravens which I kind of thought then
the Ravens should have just pounded it
up right in the middle with Gus Edwards
but apparently as you saw in the film
for the first time they played well the
Chargers actually did well and you know
after the first two drives they hung in
there you know that the only thing that
I love more than the Eagles is multiple
safeties on the field at a time and for
them to have like five safeties or field
for and I love the game a lot of people
would go why doesn't every team do that
right because not every team has the
depth not every team has the for
safeties that are you can trust to put
on the field and play two of them at
ally backer position yes most teams
don't have that your guy Mike Davis from
the pre seasons really turned into one
hell of a player supplier really I'm
pretty good all right so let's start off
with the Ravens offense the Chargers
defense you're pretty good I hear you
but the Ravens offense
I mean Universal calls for Joe Flacco
yesterday universal what did you think
of that whole side of oh they just I
don't I thought they were really people
saw a bad Flacco was the season no and I
think they they listened they were they
eating on the edge like I thought like
every time I was like oh if Lamar has a
bad series here Joe's coming in but on
those series he always had completions
or did something to go okay leave him in
okay this is where they got John
Harbaugh is a Super Bowl winning coach
because he doesn't abandon the plan just
because it was a bad 30 minutes of
football or whatever it may be and even
though the Chargers again were there
clearly the better football team on the
field there they were two minutes left
the ball with the ball good ball down
six at the 45 yard line
yeah I think that was amazing in itself
and I think that justifies the fact that
they kept Lamar in just that in itself
and I know it wasn't perfect rambles the
throws to play - Crabtree when he rolled
out to the sidelines yeah he made it
he's jump off to Dixon when he rolled
around from that was an amazing leader
when James couldn't get it I mean that
was a gutsy and Greg reminded me of
hacker Seahawks from a few years it was
kind of like that you're right um but
you know hey Lamar also with that the
fact that they kept him in and he did
battle back it made some place in the
end that was great but I'm also not
gonna give a little more free pass and
he's the one that dug them in the hole
early and I don't want to just say him
I'm gonna include Greg Roman and Marty
morning wagon in this conversation too
but one thing we saw throughout the year
when Lamar took over from exchange
problems yeah what's that abut it's been
going on in every game and Tony Romo we
referred to he goes if you've been
watching the Ravens they put two or
three on the ground every week but
they've always seemed to recover them
and they just didn't recover them all
this time but that's what happens when
you're doing the read option you're
putting the ball in the belly the
running backs different backs
sometimes you adjust your distance from
the center and the shotgun because it
might be a certain running play you
might want to get a little closer to the
line I'm gonna get a little farther so I
thought one of the snaps was very hot
and hard which was not fair to him to
handle um the biggest thing I would take
from this I thought the Ravens were
ignorant and their game plan they love
that phrase they thought they were gonna
come out and just be like we're the
Baltimore Ravens and this is what we do
we just overpower you and sing game plan
as week 15 and I'll give a deep dive
when we do the the Wednesday podcast but
it looked very exactly the same to me I
mean and you know I mean I pay attention
to the little intricate details of the
run game and things like that as I watch
because I want to go what are they doing
different but no it was all the same
stuff and what I would say is they
really made it hard on Lamar run on
first run on second hey its third nine
can you bail us out I mean that's a
shitty way to play quarter Ravens and
Seahawks offensive game plans felt very
similar yes and and for different
reasons and we'll get to that in a
minute but I didn't think they gave him
any chance to gain confidence or get in
the flow of the game no scream was a
little squirrely over the middle what
you know what I mean there was nothing
ever what we would call in the NFL Drive
starters yeah they didn't really give it
to Mark Andrews till the very end
not nothing there was nothing cute and
creative to go oh there's a nice easy
completion for Lamar it's just like a
basketball should I get to the
free-throw line and see one go in and
I'll send you go ok wait this isn't that
hard like they were just trying to smash
it constantly and to your point about
the for safety thing
this is where what was so effective dose
Bradley's a great coach I've been around
Gus he may have just coached himself
into a head come on he deserves to be I
mean he got stuck with Blake bortles in
Jacksonville so let's be real about that
okay now what he built me wrong got to
take crime exactly right I mean that's
his defense and they're running his
scheme and he picked those but this is
where my theory of the for safety is why
they do it first of all I think it gets
their best 11 on the field second of all
I think they realized wait why are we
even try to get big against Baltimore we
can't get that big and Brandon even
wasn't even there right so I think they
said like forget it like we're not
really going to get big why are we
fooling ourselves the strength of our
team is our speed and I think that's
where he just said let's just cause
speed chaos for these big lumbering you
know long necked dinosaurs these big
dinosaurs they got on the old line that
yeah maybe don't move that well but can
move people out of the way I'm trying to
find this but I'm almost positive
Chargers do this is from the athletic
yeah Chargers defenders saw that the r8
Ravens offense though complex seemed to
change little week to week they solved
parts of it like Ronnie Stanley's feat
remember the storyline last year where
people can identify a runner a pass
based on his set well when he set them
about even it was a run and when he sent
his left foot further back it was a pass
almost a hundred percent of the time
that's what happens in playoff football
it isn't that crazy that they deduced
the Ravens complete game plan - Ronnie
Stanley's feet and this is not the first
time we've seen no it's not and it's
this is what happens in playoff football
and that empowers the coach to go oh man
is a winner dot you know win or go home
situation let's put all our eggs into
that or let's take a chance every now
and then when we see those type of
alignment issues right tell us you look
for those tells but yeah I think
ultimately that's what they tried to do
at the end of the day they just said we
don't think they can block our speed
let's make a mess of things and then
keep some guys like Derwin James or
Phillips or Bose on the edge for Lamar
when he keeps the ball and they did a
great job with that our guy melvin
ingram was a monster yesterday yeah no
one has ever had a stat line like that
before
i think it was two sacks force fumble
fumble recover
all that stuff and seven tackles he's
the second best football friends we know
though what's the first me you and me
did I tell you that George kid old diem
to me pictures of him and Trent Taylor
and said were better friends than you
and yeah like when they were posing and
taking pictures together like didn't
dress up and all that no like another
set I saw like one was like cowboys and
everything they just keep sending me
more say that they're better friends
than us I mean they're not okay they
together right now but they're like I
guess we're here I think so I mean is
one of them wearing a ski mask but can
the Chargers do that seeing game plan to
the Patriots to a degree it's a
different animal and there's a lot
smarter and a lot more diverse so but
but why not put that much speed on the
field at all I think they will for the
most part because the Patriots are not
that fast
no the Patriots are not that fast but
the Patriots are gonna be the Patriots
are not as big as Baltimore they're
still gonna have a size advantage but
where they're gonna have a different
advantage that Baltimore didn't as is
their old line as better athletes than
Baltimore so Shaq Mason pulling you said
in a text that the Chargers focused on a
Hurst oh they talk about that well they
they do I think there's two people and
we talked a little bit on the the
podcast last week where Orlando Brown
had issues with Bosa
and Ingram master yes that was the two
people they attacked okay no no no oh so
went around Orlando branding at the last
trip sacked vamos it was awesome he's
very good player but I think that was
the one thing I noticed too as I was
watching the game when it was an obvious
past situation they made sure they got
Bosa and Ingram matched up against Hurst
which is their weak link on their
offensive line their right guard who
they eventually took out of the game
Apple went go in yeah so you're telling
me the wheat part of that lion was right
guard right tackle yes and were they
putting both Ingram boats on the same
they did a little bit of both but they
always made sure one of them was kind of
unhurt and they both abused him figure
out where the weak link is just through
tons of studying defensive line coach
coming in to give his two cents going
hey I've just watched this guy pass set
you know in my defense in lying room a
hundred and fifty times in a row
and he has hard times with these type of
guys or this move or this you know so
that's really what it comes down to and
yeah when they got them behind the
chains I knew they were gonna pass that
was a mismatch for the Chargers and they
took advantage of it
Chargers offense yeah what'd you think I
mean nothing special the fact is I think
that just they got touchdowns early
instead of having to settle for too many
field goals right there I don't know why
I'm wrong I only got they got no
touchdowns I'm wrong
they was it was all short amazing there
they are amazing let's see my big point
or take away from there was I really
think that more than anything the
Chargers just didn't let the Ravens
defense ruin the game right
no like big turnover no sack no like
here you got the ball at the five yard
line or I threw a dumb pic when we're
backed up I think like there was the
there was a I get a field goal early on
and I can't remember the exact situation
and I'll have a better on when I we go
to the deep dive breakdown but I
remember people I was watching the game
with going maybe they should go for it
here and I was like no this is a game
like you're fine you might have to win
12 to 6 yes or 12 to 9 yes and you take
every point possible and you don't go Oh
forth in a yard and a half we can move
around the Baltimore Ravens deal
question for the Saints culture chiefs
I'm not going for it unwraps and I'm
like down I'm not going for it yeah
those four teams it's a shootout like
I'm not kicking a field goal against the
Patriots yeah
I'm not leaving points on the field
against the patron I certainly wouldn't
know I think you lovers didn't throw it
great yesterday I thought his arm looked
a little weak of a few throws and I know
there was win going in one direction to
say you're rooting for Phillip I am
rooting for Phillip alright Simpson left
go breaking news Chris Sims is admitting
he's rooting for Phillip Rivers I am I'm
rooting against Philadelphia and he's
rooting for Phil Rivers yes I am I'm
rooting for Phil Rivers you know hey
listen I love Patrick mahomes of course
I always respect the New England
Patriots and I really like Andrew Luck
and Chris palette it's it's it's a year
where I really enjoy all these teams but
yeah Phillip Rivers I feel a little bit
similar to like John Elway in 1997 when
I was a seventeen-year-old junior in
high school
and had watched John Elway fail in the
Super Bowl as I grew up and people blame
him even though I wanted to be like are
you kidding me do you really think that
Broncos team was as good as that 49er
team so I would say you're the hill that
you will die on is that quarterbacks get
blamed for too much that isn't their
fault yes or get credit too much exactly
right was the John Elway debate like the
first time that you were like seeing
that the rest of the public put too much
on John Elway because in retrospect the
fact that he was getting blamed for
anything looks ridiculous yeah well yes
I would say that was one of the first
times I was really aware of it cuz I
remember like ivory I want to say maybe
around the Redskins Super Bowl loss with
John Elway when they lost 42 to 10 I
think I made a comment and my dad like
John Elway he's not I could picture my
own son saying this day yeah John always
alcohol he lost two Super Bowls and I
remember my dad kind of like setting me
straight like oh no Chris tried John
Elway might be the best quarterback in
the NFL it's not his fault they're
losing and that kind of opened my eyes
to it and yeah I mean I that was my
first instance of going no wait they
don't even get to the Super Bowl if they
don't have John Elway there's no they
had no business being there he was the
reason because of so many clutch moments
and unbelievable plays and then yeah
they get to the Super Bowl and they're
overmatched you know it's a little bit
like Peyton Manning went through with
the Colts that sometimes where there oh
number one proceed and they got upset
he's such a choke artist there's no more
toothpicks and the Patriots have a big
no they were like a 10 and 16 that he
fooled you into thinking they're 13 and
3 cuz the sheriff delivered in the
fourth quarter like every time also the
AFC South sucked for a very long while I
don't know if there's any thing with the
Chargers is they're the only team that I
feel like is better after their scripted
plays like I watched the bear or
scripted plays I go man that's the I
wish that offense was like that all game
I vote the Chargers are never have good
scripted plays and it's like fill up
figures out the defense in the second
and fourth quarters well I think my
number one yeah I think there's some
truth to that I do yeah they are a team
that kind of like figures out how are
they attacking us
and they adjust with their own set of
play their game but their initial game
plan never seems to work yeah I would
agree well I would say this really one
of the under-the-radar things we haven't
been tucked the Chargers offense has
really struggled down the stretch and we
haven't hasn't really got no that's why
I kept betting against them yeah I mean
the bangles game it's struggled okay the
Chiefs game I know they came back and
got two late touchdowns than win the
game but it wasn't a good performance
throughout the game you know they
struggle to I know it wasn't great
either they had the they had the lucky
touchdown catch off the Hayden dropped
interception right
the Broncos game at the end of the year
that wasn't an impressive it was not so
that oddly enough we were questioning
their defense going in the playoffs
another big enough and they have the
size and yeah as I was watching that
game yesterday I was going damn this is
like the fifth week in a row the
Chargers offense hasn't really kind of
hit on also mean and Alan is a great
receiver but he's a first down guy not a
touchdown yeah he needs other guys
around him I look at their tight ends I
don't see anything there Melvin Gordon
and Eckler they just don't look the same
guys there's not the same amount of
bursts Melvin Gordon was breaking all
these tackles and beginning the year not
doing anything I was wearing two big
bulky knee braces there's two guys on
that team that I believe should be
getting the ball more and they got the
ball more in the Kansas City game Mike
Williams and Travis Benjamin both of
those guys are the most athletic guys on
the Chargers when they needed a big play
they isolated him on Jimmy Smith in zero
coverage and threw it over the top
because guess what Mike Williams the
50/50 ball to Mike Williams is more of a
75 to 25 it's the reason you took him
7th overall out of Clemson we saw what
he did with the Shaun Watson lob it up
he's bringing it down and Travis
Benjamin is faster than 95% of the NFL
that amazing throw from Phillip Rivers
in Kansas City that he threw when he
wasn't even open yet that was Travis
Benjamin bending that bad boy and out
run in the corner there yeah generally
believe that those two guys need hit the
ball more and I wish Phillip took more
shots earlier in games to try and just
just on Mike Williams I would have to do
that this week
you have to yeah playing the Patriots
those corners they're gonna challenge
them they're gonna have some man better
better team won that game as well though
chargers charges is a better team no
doubt about it I think the better team
won all four games my no doubt not it
for my money and I know I don't know
everything but and I would argued going
in that the Bears were the better team
you did argue yeah and bloody wrong but
the question came through that know they
they proved it to me and I'm willing to
say that you were a chicken but $10 a
chicken well because I bet 15 or so it
cost 70 on the Cowboys confident - one
and a half which is one of against which
that game now yes one of the greatest
moments in gambling history the line
closed at Cowboys two and a half and
they're up ten and you're going this
game is over
but literally on this podcast let's see
if I have that video you bet your ass I
do on this podcast I said I only did
twenty three to twenty twenty seven
seventeen
I have 23:13 with like the famous
Russell Wilson touchdown with 1:15 left
and without getting the kickoff on-site
so it ended up 24:22 the famous Russell
Wilson touchdown with 118 left but
because Janikowski got hurt attempting
an insane field goal at the end of the
half the Seahawks decided to go for two
instead of trotting out Michael Dixon
their punter to maybe drop kick a field
goal and by getting the two the Cowboys
win 24 to 22 and all of those gamblers
that had Cowboys - two and a half lost a
sure thing that's horrible
the amount of people Sims that came for
my neck saying there's no way I got the
Cowboys at one and a half
right it's the first time where I wanted
to call Josh and thank him for making us
do our pick show on Thursdays I went
through and looked at the trends there
was one day in which the line was one
and a half it was two on Tuesday it was
one and a half at Wednesday when we got
the lines we start this podcast at 12:30
on Thursday at 12:30 - the line went
back to - oh isn't that wild
it is wild we got that half point but it
really did screw Vegas there's a lot of
people that bet Cowboys at - one and a
half one and the people that took the
Seahawks at plus two and a half they won
so Vegas lost twice right unbelievable
incredible betting I know I felt weird
during that game because the pressure
was off me once the Colts dominated it I
was kind of like it would be nice if the
Cowboys didn't cover but I put a lot of
money in the Cowboys Tuesday I wanted to
be right
Cowboys dominated that game for the
first two quarters and like I said we're
up six nothing and it just should that's
the scary thing about the Cowboys
Cowboys was clearly the better team
dominated the game for the most part
that is what's scary about the Cowboys
is they can be dominating a game and you
look up and you go damn they're only up
three nothing they've been kicking the
crap out of this team you know had a
chance also to put the game away earlier
when they were in field goal position
was that late or is that early fourth
quarter when he threw the interception
to KJ right in the endzone which was was
that pass interference low it's probably
pass interference and it was certainly
under thrown by about five yards so I'm
not throwing it under thrown - you're
back up tight end yeah it's just dak
Prescott had a few of those plays every
game the last few weeks and that he has
that third and 14 boy that wasn't
amazing I was playing the game right
there I was to me that's the defining
play of Jack Prescott's career at this
yeah it really is for the most part but
that that was a huge play would you say
his flip holy crazy that was amazing I
mean it really was and a third and 14
play that then gave him the touchdown to
go up by 10 yes which was huge and then
of course the other big thing and goes
back to what we worried about with the
Seattle Seahawks Seattle Seahawks run
deep
not very good one of the worst per play
rush defenses in football and really the
only reason they're not that one of the
worst rush defenses in football because
most teams go well we think we could
throw in them they play all these
eight-man fronts and they kind of scare
people from running but the big run by
Ezekiel Elliott before the half was over
that was a huge play if I had memory
serves me right yes Seattle's up six to
three and Dallas is kind of just going
let's see if we can maybe jump-start a
drive and get into field goal range and
just go in six to six then they get a
third and one and they eat then the
Seahawks don't set the edge on the right
side to me like the safety King didn't
play the outside gap the right way just
outran Zeke when 44 yards up the
sideline went out of bounds and they
scored a touchdown to go up ten to six
and that was a huge part of the game
really to me right there that's where
the Seahawks lost that they had been
outplayed came back took the lead six to
three in a game and they were being
outplayed and then had to go into
halftime ago Dan we're down ten six
that's things I thought the drive that
culminated with the DAK flip was the the
way in which the Cowboys can advance it
was the 40 yard throw to Amari Cooper
where he caught it outran people then it
was a Zeke run right up the middle for
like 20 yards and then it was dak using
his feet in the red zone
that's the Cowboys formula getting
Cooper in space
pounding you a Zeke and then Dax legs in
the red zone or a very viable weapon
they really are he's such a big man and
I'd like to see them continue to do that
certainly Seattle social media just so
upset with Schottenheimer and their play
calling for Russell Wilson Pete Carroll
comes out today and says I wish we threw
it more Russell Wilson's coming out now
and saying that you know it was working
when we were throwing I wish I kept
throwing on play-action they were
something like 10 and 11 and he was he
was doing anything he wanted we saw in
the second half that fourth and sixth
row rocket to Doug Baldwin it wasn't
like they over ran it that's alright I
just felt like run run Russ save oh I
got it
run Russ saver but now everybody wants
to say this I mean this is but Sims you
know that in the playoffs people don't
pay attention the regular
season because they're looking at their
fantasy teams or their or their watching
like I'm 12 games at once so here this
is when they this is why guys get upset
and fired yeah well I mean this is again
this is what got the Seahawks there this
style of play and I told you earlier
today there was two plays where they cut
to Pete Carroll and they were on the
excuse me offensive side of the ball and
he grabbed his coaching mic and I could
read his lap lips go run it okay so
first of all that's a organizational
institutional philosophy that's the type
of play style they want to play
defensive coaches love to play that
style especially when they know their
defense that's their little baby is
overmatched on the other side of the
ball like they were right so they're
playing to protect their favorite entity
which is their defense so that's the
first thing but that this is the way the
Seahawks have played all year long you
didn't become the number one rushing
team in the NFL by throwing the ball all
over the so you can't have it both ways
football fans that's just not the way it
works yeah no you know and you got
Russell Wilson well this is the other
thing that adds to it though this is why
everybody comes out and says this
because they look at the last drive when
they're down by 10 and Dallas plays a
soft zone prevent defense and they've go
through three plays and they're already
down in the field and then two plays
later they scored touchdown everybody
goes look that was so easy why didn't
they been doing that all the game
because Dallas didn't play those
defenses all game they weren't as
aggressive there now Russell made a
great play and there was greatness from
him I mean he's great but they also
realize that if they first of all Dallas
controlled the clock okay so they're
worried about their defense being just
absolutely overpowered and gassed out
right and then the other part of it is
come on it's the worst there what like
the worst pass protecting offensive line
in football worse than the Texas second
worse they got sacked the two most out
of any quarterbacks in football a lot of
people would say it's because they're
mobile quarterbacks and they put
themselves in those certainly I would
also say they have prehistoric past
protections and they just they have a
lot of big guys that don't move their
feet that well and they're not good pass
protectors so they understood that they
weren't going to be able to
live with Russell Wilson dropping back
to throw if he became that type of game
Dallas would have adjusted and it would
have been it would have changed and you
would have saw Russell Wilson running
around and nobody open and they just
didn't want to play that style that's
not what they were this year so the
first round pick of Rashad Penny doesn't
look so good it's gonna be good I don't
have any doubt about it it really would
be good I know he's still banged up and
he's been dealing with injuries he's
more talented than those other guys who
just you know I just had a weird year
how did you feel after the game about
the Cowboys going forward the Cowboys
are you know they're scary for both
sides of the coin cuz like we said they
can dominate a game and you look up it
to go then they're losing 6-3 I mean
they in in this game against the Rams
they could be up like 13 to 3 in the
third quarter and then the Rams get like
a touchdown and there's a Cowboys fan
you're going holy crap yeah right we
could lose this game there's no doubt
about that but they can also win these
type of games there's a - so there are a
dangerous football team I don't think
I've ever seen the final eight so wide
open
you could justify any Super Bowl matchup
in my opinion where I can literally say
like if somebody was like I think it's
gonna be this team ultra then I would
just go OK I could soon I mean it's not
crazy other years I'd go like you're
insane there's no way that can happen
this year you can literally go on both
sides and go yeah ok like Colt Eagles
yeah and there's the there are the two
number six seats yeah right I know I
mean it's like I don't expect you guys
to beat the Saints this weekend but it's
why the Steelers should be so pissed
yeah no doubt they got in they would
have been very dangerous
what else about that game do we miss
anything else just trying to think -
Blake Charmin had a few good catches
line I just was really happy that the
Cowboys stayed patient with their run
game they did that they played to their
strengths I thought that was a big
positive the football game and I guess
that would be the about it hey listen it
was a great year for the Seattle
Seahawks they exceeded expectations gosh
and they're building towards the future
and really have a chance again to go on
another run here with you know a few a
good draft and a few free agents and
watch out Seattle's back in the mix I
mean I really respected what Seattle did
this year I really did this is a year
nobody expected them to be real
competitive and it just shows you that
they have great they have a great
overall view of the game and know how to
coach and play complimentary football
and they also showed me that Pete
Carroll and John Schneider have an
incredible eye for talent and knew what
they were doing made you think that well
just they knew what they were doing when
it was okay Earl Thomas you want to sit
out fine and we got tedric Thompson we
think he's pretty good and he is or you
know okay Richard Sherman you can go we
got Shaquille Griffin we'll be all right
and we'll make it happen I mean I think
they they knew what they had as far as
guys that could help out the team and
still be competitive this year super
happy Tyler Lockett had the year he did
yeah man was that incredible I think you
know what the other thing I took away
from Cowboys Seahawks yeah the worst
part about football is what happened
Allen Hurns oh here Allen Hurns catches
this slant on a big third down the first
half and I'm going ooh are we about to
get Allen Hurns as an x-factor in this
game it's a gruesome injury of a clear
pop apparently it came through the skin
but there's man this is the thing about
your sport is when it's the game shut
down for 15 minutes and we're all
watching this man coming to grips with
his season is done who knows what's
gonna happen to next year in his
contract he's thinking about all the
money although all the repair that I
didn't watch it I came watch but just to
sit there for 15 minutes and all the
momentum from like excitement about the
game is turned off and I eat it us out
that that's the hardest part about
football and their responses I got were
stop being a wimp football's a tough
game and I'm going see y'all don't even
give a [ __ ] about this guy y'all don't
care for you it's like injuries are a
part of football yeah fine but like I'm
just saying that when I turn on the NBA
Finals draymond Green doesn't break his
leg in the second game he's not laying
on the ground and we go wait his foots
turned the wrong way like our eye guy
knew Allen Hurns was her
we're salty was laying down and I was
like wait his foots going the wrong way
it doesn't look like the other foot oh
man
Steph Curry no worries though next guy
up he'll be fine it's it's just a hard
thing about the NFL is because like when
you watch it all the time and you cover
it the matchups mean something to you
and the humans mean something to you and
for all those people out there there
were telling me to suck it up and stop
being a win man I just NFL Twitter and
social media is really bad like compared
to the other sports I know I'm
ridiculous wearing a ski mask right now
but it'll probably be big on social oh
man it's gonna kill
but like MBA social media is like so fun
and it's all about like the the
enjoyment and the NFL social music
you're wrong you're an idiot
your team sucks I hope they get hurt
like it's just the dumbest people yeah
well there's more meat headedness in
football the fans the players all of it
so I get that in you know now that
you're here at this point I'm gonna say
what I've always wanted to say about
this whole thing Cerf no oh this is
where I believe how's it going gloves
the gloves the gloves that players are
wearing the gloves that you see all the
receivers make these amazing one hand
catches for you if you haven't tried
them on anybody up there it's like glue
go get a pair and you'll go dim it's
easy to catch the ball with them yeah
I'm Keyshawn I mean yeah and then still
hey listen these receivers got talent
and they got great hands regardless but
this is what scares me about the gloves
and this is where I think it's a player
health problem okay
and hear me out the gloves what they are
doing and like you saw with Allen Hurns
guys don't fall off of players anymore
because they can hold on to anything
with those gloves you could hang
somebody from the George Washington
Bridge with those gloves and he can hang
there for three hours before he'd lose
grip that's how strong it is I mean it's
it's truly unbelievable if you have not
tried it but to me the big issue is and
you've seen me explaining this before is
hey when I was growing up and Walter
Payton or Emmitt Smith they stiffed arm
somebody people went trying to hold him
they'd go down I'm gonna stand up for
this now
you got a great running back look let's
say c'est quoi barkal and he pushes the
guy and he should go down because he's
50 pounds lighter than say Quan Barclay
and say Kwan's got an explosive right
thing but they have these gloves and
they don't fall so then they fall but
they bring you with them and all of a
sudden they're running back or the
runner is stuck in collapses on his leg
with the guy falling on his leg and
that's where I do a new thing that's why
with Allen Hurns no doubt about it there
was a number of tackles in that game
Seattle knows how to what I would call
like hog-tie and fall they love to just
grab and we're gonna let all they just
like call them jerk you down and it's a
dangerous way to play I know some teams
don't like it they think it's somewhat
dirty how they do it but it's not dirty
it's just physical and they're getting
you to the ground dirtiness is allowed
in my foot but I do think the gloves
thing is real man I really do I see it a
number of times I see guys making
one-handed tackles on 240 pound running
backs and they just stick out a hand and
grab it onto the jersey and they pull
guys to the ground and I'm just telling
you the guy that's holding them with one
handed he's not that strong you know but
since he has that glove on he could
never lose loses that grip I think it's
one of the smarter things you've said
Thanks and because you said two smart
things in your life congratulation thank
you very much what was the other one the
other one was you know what I like this
left go guy no I think you're absolutely
right and I think I think you really
have to try the gloves to understand
because when the first time I put the
gloves on is the first time I said I
could do a jugs machine cuz you just
feel like a superhuman you feel like
spider-man Yeah right I've never
experienced anything like it before yeah
but it does suck that happens to Allen
Hurns Colts Texans man this one went
according to play now all these games we
went for no I went three and one but oh
did you oh yeah well that sucks
Colts Texans um I got a I got a lot of
DM after that game going should Bill
O'Brien lose his job no I no definitely
not I mean this is the first time you've
gone to the playoff so the real
quarterback so you know let's let's be
patient there they got some issues on
their third roster they need to fix
all the things we worried about with the
Texans all came to true right that it's
all deshaun Watson that they're running
their offensive line can't block good
defenses and open up holes for the run
game it's all about him and Hopkins just
making it happen and like I said Hopkins
did not play well against the I'm really
interested to see what they did to you
know just as far as how they approached
us a lot of we were saying that Hopkins
was a little bit banged up yeah at some
point but no yeah I'm interested to see
that for when's right-t why he'll did tu
i Hilton things against the Texans like
he always writes because that past
events is bad and we thought like right
we were wondering where the one all over
it well we just you know it's it was a
bad match over the Texans because I have
never seen - yeah pushed around like
that yeah do this offensive line the
best in football I want to say that like
all NFL players are enormous the linemen
are always big yeah there have been a
few that when we went to Dallas and we
saw a Greg Hardy and Tyler Smith that it
really impacted me because I thought
they were huge even seeing the video of
the Colts offensive lines sitting on the
bench they're bigger than I'm used to
see it yeah they're impressive - they're
like put together yeah differently than
a normal big guy to have a little some
athletic looking traits to their bigness
which I still want to come in and go is
it quit Nelson that good and of course
he is but it's just it's wild that he's
that good right away I know just like
Zach Martin was it's really it's firm
it's it's it's unbelievable two guys
from the same school
Nelson is so good that we don't talk
about Zack Martin anymore no you're
right
which is why you're right I think he
took the throne of the best guard in
football this year but this is why the
Colts are dangerous and this is why the
Colts are dangerous against the Kansas
City Chiefs because guess what Kansas
City's got a horrible past Aoife it's
just like the texans and they rely on
Jones Houston and D Ford to get after
the quarterback to save that secondary
and that is not going to happen against
this offensive line so that's where I go
Tim would I be shocked if the Colts
upset the Kansas City Chiefs no but
getting back to this game I mean that
was the game is the fact that their old
line had that way with Daddy line and
you heard me say that JJ Watt kind of
fell off down the end
I mean still really good don't get me
wrong but yeah the Texans are built on
we need our D line to dominate and make
a mess of things and they found the one
team that said huh you're not making a
mess of us we can pass protect against
you all day long and when we run I mean
there was a few runs in that game left
go I was like oh my gosh they collapsed
the whole side of oh it was incredible
how well coach they are how good who's
the coach of the year for you so I would
say Frank right already right Anthony
Lin I'm gonna say Nagy at or - I'm gonna
say Sean Payton should not for I think
Belichick should be up for it - because
when you look at the Patriots roster the
fact that they ended up with a bi is
insane I also think Andy Reid should be
up there as a possible coach I know it's
a tough year and he's never gonna get
mentioned so that was most of the teams
that was tickets Riker Lynn in my
opinion what why did you narrow it down
to those two because I just think those
are two guys who
so the typical coach of the year goes to
the guy that turns it around the most
right rike is right out there they had a
top five pick Lynn just missed the
playoffs last year nagy fourth in the
NFC North turned it around right yeah I
just look at Reich in that situation I
mean come on just like he held up last
week most of us I think even me included
had him like 29 and their first Power
Rankings you know most people had him as
xxxii best football when they started so
that to me and to start one in five and
turn it around and get your team to
believe that's a huge deal Anthony Lynn
I give him because the Chargers have
been cursèd they've messed up football
games for the last seven or eight years
now they moved to LA you know had all
these issues and I'm not giving it to
Matt Nagy because first of all the
defense was phenomenal already and they
got Khalil Mack and to me Ryan pays
should be executive of the year because
you're getting his army yeah
Ryan pace is my executive a year which
knocks out Negi Andy Reed Patrick
mahomes is the MVP so he doesn't get it
Bill Belichick I don't think had as
great as some of the other guys and they
did slow off on some
my coach of the year is gonna be Sean
Payton because I believe that no one
consistently came out with great game
plans more than Sean Payton
I thought he motivated them through the
tough part of their schedule
I thought he won most of the big games
that they've played and I thought his
willingness to incorporate all those
other pieces in the offense guys I've
never heard of before sure what he did
with Taysom Hill was a coaching marvel
he ran plays in formations we've never
seen I would say Sean McVeigh was the
leader in the clubhouse through the
first eight weeks he hit that Buy and it
went out the window but I think the
battle in my mind this is the left go
vote which is non-official would be
Reich versus Payton and I would go with
Sean Payton but I think Chris Ballard
and pace are up for executive of the
Year right but I think for me it's Reich
and Payton yeah yeah I got know if Sean
Payton won the award I'd be happy he's
the best coach of the NFL oh yeah no I
mean really it to me if Payton Reich
Payton Reich or Anthony Lynn win it I'm
happy there either way Matt Nagy did
some really good things I get that I'm
gonna sit here and tell you though I
still don't love the Bears offense I
just don't and I don't see people for a
day long yeah it is a lot of horizontal
and I know Mitchell too risky still
learning it may be the full offense
isn't even in yet but fascinating year
man I'm just I don't remember it ever
being this wide open and the matchups
this week could go either way
all right so I have some numbers right
here from I believe I don't wanna give
credit this is bet online right for
likelihood of Super Bowl matchups what
do you believe is the most likely Super
Bowl matchup right now Saints Patriots
it is Saints Chiefs at four to one Wow
it is Saints Patriots at five to one his
home-field advantage so I would take
Saints Chiefs right now but I am really
solely betting taking that if Sammy
Watkins is playing if he wasn't that
would change me third is Rams Chiefs
which I think it's fun to think about
all the notions Rams chief that rematch
oh my gosh yeah the numbers would be
insane the one after that is Rams
Patriots and eat to one so that's two
versus two after that at Saints chargers
and eight to
the least likely is Eagles cults at 33
to 1 and tied with them is Cowboys Colts
at 33 to 1 not a bad bet no none of them
are bad so your Eagles are really the
team I mean the Eagles have the hardest
thing about these storylines think about
these storylines Saints Chiefs Brees
mahomes MVP battle Saints Patriots Shaun
peut Drew Brees vs. Tom Brady will take
over 82 years of quarterbacks
unbelievable
Rams Chiefs rematch from that incredible
game Rams Patriots the future of
coaching versus the greatest coach
that's ever been Saints Chargers Drew
Brees let go from his former team taking
on Philip Rivers Saints Colts rematch
from the Super Bowl in which Sean Payton
kicked the onside kick Rams Chargers the
Battle of LA Rams Colts that's a little
hard Rams Colts offensive explosion
Andrew Luck vs. Sean McVeigh maybe
quitted be like that old line verse that
drams deal I know that big Nelson verse
Donald Cowboys Chiefs Wow that'll be
wild that would be Patrick mahomes
versus the America's Team
Eagles Chiefs Andy Reed versus his
former Protege Doug Peterson Cowboys
Patriots I mean that might be the
highest-ranking Super Bowl ever basis
Eagles Patriots we just saw last year
Cowboys Chargers Zeke versus Gordon
sounds great they're all good to me
though I don't look at any of them ago
oh that would be a bad match bad game
right why do we not want to break down
Texans Colts I just felt like it was
bleep well I think we we kind of got it
to all of it we talked about the we kind
of predicted that one to well well yeah
I mean I think we had a good feel for
that game in general and it kind of just
laid out there in front of us I mean we
saw one offense come out and get the
ball twice and go oh we can run oh we
can protect and throw oh we can run we
could protect them throw we're up 21
nothing shocking and then we saw another
offense that we said damn it's only
about two guys
every week and they can only run on
their really shitty run defenses in
football they can never run the ball on
any respectable defense and that all
kind of came true and we just kind of
watched it happen but yeah they you know
the Texans got to get better up front on
the offensive line they got to get more
diverse with passing schematics I do
think they're a little too simple there
they got to change their approach on the
offensive side of the ball just a little
bit and expand and the Colts are you
know quietly flying under the radar here
I don't know why it's quiet
I've already probably not cool I've
already told you that the underdogs in
the last two playoffs are 15 and 1 and
I'm not gonna lie I love all 400 let's
get the lines already headlines do you
want to guess I'm sure we're gonna steal
something from Bill Simmons but he's
stolen things from everybody so it's
even Cowboys at Rams what do you think
the Rams are favored mmm don't look
no I'm not looking I got NFL Jesus open
just say no I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
Rams by 5 grams by 7 oh wow taking the
Cowboys I would bet Cowboys money line
their cure that means they just pick him
to win yeah ok and you get a lot more
money here say they're gonna win right
Chiefs Colts Colts at Chiefs Colts at
Chiefs
I'm gonna say it's Chiefs by six and a
half very close Chiefs by six okay I the
Colts at six so yeah great yeah I think
that's just scary about the Chiefs is
yeah - Tyree killed bombs in the road
game to be tied and he throws a bomb but
look if you bet Colts money line there I
don't think you're crazy I think you're
crazy they're chargers Patriots these
are what they open - yeah so patch I
don't know this is still this is pretty
accurate Pats are favored man I'm gonna
say the Pats are favored by a touchdown
four and a half wow smallest online of
the week and you know what if you took
Chargers moneyline I don't think you're
crazy no I agree
and then II go at least like league
that's the one I don't like yes maybe
spread but Eagles Saints
hmm okay so st. because the weird thing
about the AFC is the Colts own the
Chiefs and the playoffs and the Patriots
own the Chargers if you're looking at
history so I guess I'm gonna say Saints
by 8 exactly okay put me in Vegas and
you know what if you bet the Eagles
money line I don't think you're crazy
you think I wouldn't bet that bet I
wouldn't bet any of these bets I don't
bet all right unless it's fake money
what which game are you most excited to
watch on film from this past oh the what
I'm most excited to watch on film I
think is Eagles bears followed by
Chargers Ravens followed by Cowboys see
Hawks cuz I know what happened to him I
know Colts really I know that Texans
really well and I know what they do on
defense and I feel like I got a pretty
good feel for the Colts offense to where
that game was kind of played out the way
I expected and what we saw on TV was
almost positive that we went like seven
and one last year in the playoffs before
the champ rights like I feel like we've
gone for now in the wild card games or
three and one for like the last few
years you think so yeah yeah the wild
cards well this is the first year where
I felt like the wild card matchups for
or real that we did I don't know here's
last year's I probably picked the Chiefs
to beat the Titans last year I don't
know the Titans had that game I picked
the Titans and I got that one right you
get it right Rams Falcons damn I don't
know who I picked we both picked the
Falcons did we yeah okay so we got that
we got bills Jaguars from last year I
got that wrong you take the bills no the
Jaguars didn't cover it was ten to seven
that 10 to 3 yeah the Jaguars were
favored by like nine whoo and then the
Saints Panthers which I know we both
took the Saints or I thought we did I oh
no we did really bad thank you everybody
we wasted your time with that five month
five minutes that you can't have hope
you guys were cool with me wearing the
ski mask the entire time
I bless you get that out of here bro st.
forceps peace out homies I on the up for
Frederick good evening sorry I was gonna
look at that camera and sign off I am
the lef koe man
we will holla holla holla at you next
time Wednesday will be fun and again
head down to Atlanta dantana's get a
room stay at an air B&B have fun we're
gonna have a blast and we're excited to
see how much weight you lose dude I'm up
do I look skinny no I'm saying you lost
weight with the mask